as a lifelong trekkie i have to ask were
you both already track used when you got
cast
um
i was a childhood man but i would not
say i was a trekkie because it'd be an
insult to other trekkies but it was
definitely a fan
so um babs the first time that you uh
got to go on to the med base that what
was it like
it was just amazing it was amazing like
wow this is
the sick bay this is my office this is
you know where we get to play
you know and uh
it was just massive and the
level of artistry that went into you
know the design
and
you know the detail and the minutiae
like just all the little pieces
it's just staggering staggering really
so
it was it was uh
it helped us settle in even more you
know really like
you know we're here and uh
we have to use this space and we have to
we have to command the space you know
um so it was it was really lovely
excellent and then jess you are both
playing a character that originated in
the original series did you feel like
you had the freedom to kind of flush it
out and bring something new to the
character absolutely um it was a really
cool process of um
uh
collaborating and speaking extensively
with akiva and henry the showrunners and
and um
taking in major's performance and um
distilling the essence of that and then
and then really having a conversation
about like who is she in 2021 who was
she when she was younger how do we marry
those things
um and
it was cool it was um you know they both
gave me
um
a lot of points about who they wanted
her to be but they also gave me a lot of
license to explore and entrusted me with
that which was
so um
it was such an honor to be trusted with
that as a as an uh as an artist
um
so yeah i mean it's been such a great
time and um
i've felt
uh
inspired and and supported by
almost everybody that i've met in the
star trek universe on every side of it
so it's been it's been a real pleasure
and an honor
excellent and then babs without spoilers
we get to see a little bit more of
mabangka's backstory at the beginning of
the season
what was it like getting to explore that
arc and what can fans expect from it
unfortunately i can't see what fans
expect from it
but
uh it was it was uh
it was a lovely uh journey to undertake
you know it was a lovely challenge to
undertake and it was
and i just tried to make sure i was
serving you know
the truth as much as possible really all
through um
yeah
jess if you could use one word how would
you describe nurse chapel oh that's hard
isn't it
um
that's so hard to choose um
[Music]
three words
for you for me yeah for you for you
um i would say
uh mischievous
very moral like she's got a really
strong moral compass um
and
that guides her more than any other
rule or regulation you know like that's
her sticking
her north star
and
i don't know that he help
no at all
okay all right
in a good way in a good way
[Music]
can you do the same for your character
for my character yes
wow
uh one word yeah just one
centered
excellent that's a good answer well
thank you both so much
thank you thank you thank you thank you
thank you